foreign
it's Monday I'm back from holiday so
let's do this GS news update thing an
alleged leak has sprung from the mighty
Dam that is Rockstar Games suggesting
that the PS4 Xbox One and PC version of
GTA 5 will contain a first person mode
it'll be part of a load of new features
that were listed on Rockstar's official
website on a post that was believed to
be unfinished but that page has now been
taken offline and while it was cached by
Google even that has now vanished
remember this is the internet this could
all be some Grand cruel hoax but if the
post was accurate the new versions of
GTA 5 will also include a newly
overhauled character selection screen as
well as a wealth of new Easter eggs and
random events for story mode they'll
also be increased draw distances finer
texture details denser traffic and
enhanced resolutions all working
together to bring new life to the city's
Town deserts and oceans of Rockstar
North's epic reimagining of Southern
California meanwhile GTA online will
benefit from an extensive array of new
jobs an arsenal of new web scores of new
vehicles new properties and player
customizations the site also states that
if you transfer a character from the
last gen version of the game you'll get
some sweet free new weapons and a free
garage for online but what about the
heist damn it the first person mode
works both on foot and in vehicles
showing your car's interior working
speedometers tachometers which is a REV
monitor I Googled it dash lights and
more GTA 5 will hit PS4 and Xbox One on
November 18th but PC owners will have to
wait until late January to shoot some
fools and take chops for a walk fake or
not there's still no word about those
long-awaited heists sorry are you ready
to head back into Los Santos are you
done with GTA 5 let me know in the
comments for the latest gaming gubbins
stay tuned to GameSpot
laughs